[Music]
do I have 2500 along 2500 LR three
thousand three thank you for a thousand
you are going once
do I hear five five thousand Alaura for
this dazzling beauty sold to my friend
with the gills for five thousand please
note while the quality of our
merchandise is guaranteed there are no
return to a dealer the deal is a
beautiful deal and to that end next up
unit 19 one of our more exotic offerings
from star sector 41 we all know what
stars
what do we do that means your face to
anyone else no anyone sold to you sir
for 3500 Alaura careful she bites I got
this first hallway 5th door
first we'll wait 6 dual 1t here we have
a very attractive representation of the
primary species of Earth this former
beauty queen tried to lead a galactic
rebellion shall we start the bidding of
$3,000 to the gentleman with the taste
for his own kind
nothing like a home
next up unit 21 this middle-aged
Splashin has delusions of royal blood
it'll temper a bit of a fixer-upper
shall we start the bidding at five
hundred so nice to be acquired by a
master of my own kind are you seeing for
the banquet tonight
no I don't like to waste time perhaps
master would like to see what his new
servant can do before we leave this star
sector if it wouldn't be wasting masters
time I suppose I could spare a minute or
two for that this room has the sturdiest
I'd like to find out the sturdiest bet
you say that sounds terrific
no peeking master promise cross my heart
hope to die we all die someday and I got
a feeling this ain't the way I go gosh
you're so tense
[Music]
maybe we should try something I'm very
impressed
well I hope you're ready for what
happens next I've been ready all day
thanks for the show but I'll be taking
that taking what this old thing
who are you relax relax
I'm general Peyton Parker from Earth's
intergalactic armed forces you remember
us right
we're the ones backing the rebellion you
started taking that orb and any other
orbs that you found so far oh not a
chance mr. Parker we know you're working
for the merge and over the orb and there
will be new trouble
give me the orb now you know I always
hated the swimsuit round at the
competition so you better believe I
didn't put on this bikini just to let
some jarhead newbie walk off with the
trophy you still have an email back
[Music]
the plane right outside that's really
hijack
girls are free Lords ours let's get off
this nasty rock I suppose I've killed
enough for cheeks for one day ardent
she's doing it over here we can't kill
them all Victoria now
Victoria
[Music]